- AWS for VMware migrations:
successes, roadmaps, and strategies.
I'm thrilled to be joined today
by three of our customers.
We have Tyler Barhydt,
he's the VP of Cloud and
Infrastructure Delivery
at Envision Healthcare.
Angel Gonzalez, Deputy
Director of Infrastructure
for Aeroméxico.
And Molly Greek,
the Chief Information Officer
at the University of California.
Thank you all for being here,
I'm really looking forward
to our discussion today.
Now, before we hear from these leaders,
I'd like to point out that AWS
is the longest standing Cloud provider
helping customers migrate
VMware workloads to the Cloud.
We understand that there's
no one size fits all solution
when it comes to Cloud
migration and modernization.
Each organization has its own unique mix
of applications and data and
infrastructure requirements,
which is why we offer customers
choice and flexibility.
Some customers may be
running VMware workloads,
which have dependencies
that they need to continue
running in the Cloud.
Others are seeking to transform workloads
through modernization,
migration and modernization,
leveraging Cloud native technologies.
Some customers have data
residency requirements,
where running AWS on premises
can help meet that objective.
And finally, some may be looking
to expand how they
virtualize their workloads,
perhaps leveraging partner solutions.
And diving a little bit deeper into this,
just AWS meets you where you
are in your Cloud journey.
We offer the most comprehensive migration
and modernization pathways
for your VMware workloads.
Customers can relocate VMware
workloads with Amazon EVS.
That's our Elastic VMware Service
for a rapid lift and shift
with minimal changes.
You can rehost on Amazon
EC2, leveraging AWS transform
for VMware to accelerate migrations.
You may have heard that we just launched
enhanced agentic AI capabilities.
This helps automate discovery,
dependency mapping, and
network translation.
We have a couple of breakout
sessions on AWS transform
for VMware later this week.
I'll have information at
the end of the presentation
about those sessions,
so be sure to check those
out if you're interested.
Customers can also re-platform
to containers with Amazon ECS
or Amazon EKS to modernize
the application architecture.
And you could leverage managed
services such as Amazon RDS,
Amazon FSX, or Amazon Workspaces.
This will help you reduce
operational overhead,
or you could completely refactor
and modernize applications with serverless
and Cloud native services
for maximum agility
and cost optimization.
Now these pathways are
not mutually exclusive.
Many customers pursue multiple
approaches simultaneously
and continue to iterate
long after the first
migration is complete.
Now, I'm curious to
hear from the audience,
how many of you are
considering a migration
of VMware workloads to the Cloud
through either with EVS or EC2?
Show of hands, it's a lot of you.
What about how many are
looking to modernize workloads
through moving to containers
or managed services
and application refactoring?
Great, so a lot of you,
think you should be very interested
in the conversation today.
Now let's get to know our
speakers a little bit better.
Tyler, can you start us off
and tell us a little bit
about Envision Healthcare
and your responsibilities there?
- Sure, like you mentioned,
I'm the VP of our Cloud
and Infrastructure Delivery
at Envision Healthcare.
About 25 years of IT experience
in various forms over the years.
Been there about two and a half years.
And we focus in on the
physicians EMHM type work.
We've got kind of an interesting model
where we actually staff physicians.
We do our revenue cycle
management work for them,
as well as scheduling
and some other things are on EMHM,
anesthesiology, radiology, et cetera.
- Great, now, Angel,
could you tell us a little
bit about Aeroméxico,
and your responsibilities?
- Sure, well, my name is Angel Gonzalez,
as you already mentioned.
Aeroméxico is one of the
largest airlines in Mexico.
We fly to over 90 destinations
in Mexico, Europe,
United States, and Asia.
Well, I'm the Deputy
Director of Infrastructure,
so I'm in charge of several parts there,
like Cloud, on-Prem services,
network, and several others.
So we've been in this
journey to the Cloud here
for years, more or less.
So, well, that's me.
- All right, thank you very much.
And Molly, could you give
us a brief introduction
and overview of your responsibilities
at the University of California?
- Sure, I've been at the
University of California
for about 15 years.
I used to work at UC Davis Health,
and now I work at the systemwide office,
which is in Oakland.
Many of you probably didn't know
there was a systemwide office,
but to just give you an idea
about the scope and scale,
we provide shared services
for the entire UC,
which is 22 different organizations,
including a large healthcare presence.
And we do things like the
undergraduate admission system
for the entire UC,
which 250,000 students
apply every year, worldwide.
We also have all the
hospitals that we support,
health systems, we have
six major health systems,
and we have the payroll and HR system
for our current employees,
which is, UC is the second
largest employer in California.
And we have the HR and
payroll and benefits system
for all of our retirees, as
well because we have a pension.
- Thank you very much.
I apologize I didn't have the slide up
about the University of
California the whole time,
so we'll leave that just for a second.
Okay, well, thank you all.
I think everyone here is
looking forward to hearing more
from our panelists as they
share their experiences.
Tyler, why don't you start us
off with Envision Healthcare.
Tell us about your migration story.
- Yeah, when I showed
up about, like I said,
about two and a half years ago.
We have on-prem infrastructure,
we have got a Cloud,
small Cloud footprint,
radiology was there, pretty heavy.
We had a lot of acquisition work,
a lot of M&A activity that
created a lot of fragmentation.
We had 11 plus data centers that were,
I'll say purpose built,
so not a lot of that traditional,
where we were doing, running all workloads
and all data centers and that.
And so we really had to
come up with an approach
that would allow us to kinda
get into a Cloud first mindset,
how do we start to migrate?
And our end goal being,
you know, flexible.
So we didn't like narrow
down AWS as our primary.
We have a few workloads that
run over in Azure as well.
But we tried to stay
very open in, kind of,
our methodologies and where we could go.
We really wanted to
focus in on consolidation
of those data centers.
How do we get through that?
How do we start to build some
operational efficiencies?
And then how do we also gain
some, you know, cost savings
and some of the other benefits
that you're gonna get through
that migration effort?
We leverage different tools
right there, up there,
transform our application
discovery services, EC2s,
RDS customs and everything else.
And so in the early days we
focused in a little bit on,
kind of, our SQL workloads,
getting into RDS, RDS custom.
We tried to, one of those
data centers I mentioned,
we were able to exit in 2025.
Some of that was data center
to data center migration.
Some of it was, again, being flexible,
moving things directly into
AWS, more of a lift and shift.
And then we also went through an effort
to migrate a bunch of
workloads to Azure ABS.
Is what we ended up using there.
We've got plans now,
we're looking to get out
of our last, kind of,
there's two more primary data
centers left from that 11.
We look to get out of that
by the end of this year,
we're probably gonna leak
a little bit into 2027.
But the tools and those things
were very useful in, kind of,
how we organized the environment,
those different methodologies
and things that we did there,
again, really focused on
how do we take the right
workloads, get them-
Initially we started out
with a little bit of the,
hey, we gotta modernize everything.
That slowed us down.
We kind of got ahead of
ourselves a little bit
and kind of moved things back and forth,
changed our policies a little bit
and kind of kept things moving, but-
- [Blankenstein] Did you have any-
Were there any AWS workshops
or anything like that that
kinda helped you along the way?
- Yeah, we did, we did.
Our two EBAs, which were very helpful.
- [Blankenstein] That's the
Experience Based Acceleration.
- Yep, thank you.
We did a couple of those.
We did one earlier this year
that was also very helpful,
so that's always been very useful to us.
We've done work,
and we've had a partner involved along
with AWS, so Presidio is our
partner there with you guys.
That's really, kind of,
helped us put some structure around it,
but we really brought in folks
and dedicated it to this effort.
We spent a lot of time up front,
I don't wanna get into the
lesson learnt piece yet,
so lemme-
- [Blankenstein] That's okay.
- Keep going on the journey.
The tooling and everything,
again, was very useful.
We did have to push folks
to kind of adopt it.
A lot of work around, we
had two organizations,
the on-prem folks and the Cloud folks.
We're all now part of one organization.
We leveraged Skill Builder,
we leveraged a lot of that
partnership with you guys on,
kind of, the efforts that we did there
to really kind of upskill
folks as we went along the way.
Deep down, I think it's been, you know,
a very positive journey and partnership
with how this works,
- Great, great.
Angel, you wanna take us through
your journey at Aeroméxico?
- Sure, well, this journey
started like four years ago.
One of the main strategies for Aeroméxico
was not doing lift and shift, per se.
We needed to make, first, an architecture.
This structure had everything
on, set on the paper.
Just to start moving and really
modernizing our application.
So we started dividing our applications.
All of our applications were based
on three main data centers.
The idea is to leave all these
three centers from premise
and go fully Cloud.
As Tyler has mentioned,
we are moving to only one Cloud, only AWS.
So that's one of our strategies.
So, we were planning, one of the goals
were to move 346, 350 applications
out of those data centers.
So we divided our strategies
in three, at the beginning,
or mainly two, refactor and re-platform
for our critical workloads.
And then we started like
looking to different options.
During this journey, we ended
up having some of obsolescence
and a major tech refresh came up for us.
So we decided to start
looking to options with AWS,
with some assessment
that you help us with,
and with a service that
you called Countdown,
also with some specialists
that you present to us,
- [Blankenstein] Countdown Premium, yeah.
- Into EVS.
So when we decided, here, to go to EVS
was because one of the main purposes here
is that our business partners
that were focused on
refactoring other applications,
they needed to focus on that.
So my team, as infrastructure,
we decided to take this
application that was left on-prem
that will take maybe 12 months to be moved
from on-premise to Cloud.
So, and one of them,
a couple of challenges
that we have there
is that they wanted to keep
our IP addressing in the Cloud.
So they don't have to make
any changes or major changes
to the applications.
And also we needed to improve some,
and start covering some
vulnerabilities in cybersecurity,
that our cybersecurity team showed to us.
So we took EVS, we started analyzing,
we start talking to our business partner
to try knowing how they are
handling their applications.
And one of our partners, DXC,
that is the one that is managing
all our on-premise applications,
helped us really, really well
because they were really
novel about the infrastructure
that we have there.
So we started looking into that.
It was like a flip coin to be honest,
because we put all our force there in EVS
and at the end it came really well.
We ended up moving 96 servers,
around more than 50
applications in only one month.
So it was really, really well for us.
And at the beginning,
just the goal was to move those loads
really, really fast to the Cloud.
But at the end we end up finding,
also more capacity for our service
in operational applications that we have.
Also, we end up finding
that some of our workloads
and applications started
running really, really fast.
So the feedback that we received
from our customers were really good.
- Not too fast.
- Not fast, but really, really good.
So WIN has performance,
WIN has cybersecurity,
WIN has a lot of things.
And, well, now we are running
a lot of our workloads.
Of course, we will talk a little
bit in the lessons learned,
but we have a couple of roadblocks.
- So it sounded like a key
thing that you were able to do
was to move the infrastructure
without disruption
to the application development.
And you did that with EVS
and the HCX technology
to stretch the networks?
- Correct, HCX, we extended our network,
our on-prem network,
and we end up moving the
workloads during night.
So no operational impact.
We are of course an airline,
so 24/7 support in our operations.
So with no impact, no impacts whatsoever
for our clients and our customers.
- Great, I know you were
an early adopter of EVS
and we thank you for that
and your feedback through all that.
So I'm glad it's working out
and helping with the rapid
lift and shift there.
All right, Molly,
I know you had some interesting
application challenges
to deal with at University of California.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that
and your journey?
- Yeah, I wish my
journey was so strategic.
What we started with was emergencies
that we had to deal with right away.
So, we had an HR payroll system
that serves about 280,000 employees.
And we had a lot of performance issues.
It was being managed by a vendor
and it was being managed
on a different platform.
And we tried to get it to be fixed,
we tried to get it better.
But every single time we
ran payroll, it took longer.
And we were really looking at the point
where at some point we wouldn't
be able to run it on time.
So that was the point
where we said enough,
we have to move to AWS.
So we moved the system over.
It took us about six months.
We worked really, really
closely with our AWS partners.
And you know, it's always nervous
when you do those types of things, right?
It's payroll.
We didn't, and we have a
lot of people that we pay.
If you don't get that right,
you're in the newspapers.
But we moved it over
and all of our performance problems, gone.
It was absolutely amazing.
I actually had the other
vendor call me the day after
and say, how's it going?
And I say, "Hey, all those
problems we used to have,
I guess it really was the
infrastructure all the time."
So really big success there.
And then we had some
other things that came up.
Like we have the undergraduate
admission system, which is,
if you ever have dealt with someone
who's applying for college,
everybody likes to wait until
the last 15 minutes to hit go.
So we have 250,000 applicants every year.
And we close at midnight, actually coming,
I think it might be today.
Last 15 minutes, about
15,000 people hit enter
and two years in a row,
our system crashed in
that last 15 minutes.
And so then we're in all the newspapers,
all the parents and the
students are panicking.
We have to extend the deadline.
And the president of the university said,
I don't care what you do,
but it can't happen in
the third year in a row.
We tried a lot of things,
a lot of performance management stuff.
But this is a classic
thing where it's down here
and then it's up here
and then it's down here
the rest of the time.
You just can't put enough
servers together for that.
So that one we partnered
with AWS, got it up there.
And what the really cool
thing about that is,
they wanted it to succeed
as much as we did.
You know, they were up
with us at, you know, 11:59
adjusting dials and all that stuff.
And, actually, even now,
it's our third year there,
they're still with us
at midnight, you know,
making sure it goes well.
We also, following that, we
had to get off the mainframe.
I know, we had a mainframe,
so we moved off the mainframe.
It was very expensive
to be on a mainframe,
if anyone has ever been on a mainframe
or maybe still on a mainframe.
And we had data that we had to keep.
We have some retention things,
we have to either keep
data for 50 or 99 years,
that's another story.
But we moved it all to AWS and
we turned off the mainframe
and saved $3 million.
And that was one where we worked
with Deloitte to get that done.
They're actually pretty good
at turning off mainframes.
And, you know, after we had
all these different successes,
then we just said enough, we
wanna just be on one platform.
So we started a project
to move everything else
and really, really lucky
because that was right about the time
that the VMware stuff was changing.
And we had a plan to get it all done
in a certain period of time.
We had to accelerate that at the end
to avoid the VMware costs, which we did.
And now we are a hundred percent in AWS.
And, you know, I think that
you really have to know
what you're doing there.
We'll talk more about lessons learned,
but we worked with partners
and, at this point,
our team is so good
because we've done it so many times
that we're a lot more comfortable with it.
- I think you mentioned you had
some security things as well
that you were trying to -
- Oh yeah, you know, one
thing I'll mention, you know,
it's not something I'm super proud of,
but I guess we're okay now.
When we moved everything over,
just by moving everything through,
we resolved about 60,000 vulnerabilities.
So that's just an important
thing to think about.
It's like we're getting
better performance.
We actually were able to reduce cost
and we resolved a lot of our
software vulnerabilities.
Part of that is, you know,
the fact that they're managing it for us,
so we don't have to constantly be patching
and patching and patching.
The other piece of it is,
it forced us to look at
everything on those servers.
I'm not gonna lie, there
was some old stuff on there
and we didn't know what it was.
So, you know, we had things out there
that had been there for 15 years.
We didn't know what it was,
but we had to go through
and figure it all out.
We had about 15 zombie servers
running stuff we didn't even need.
So by going through that
and getting rid of that stuff,
we reduced our security
vulnerability footprint
and we reduced cost.
- Fantastic.
Great, great stories.
And I think everyone's
gonna benefit from that.
We like to transition now to
our lessons learned section.
I think the audience would
love to hear from each of you
a little bit about some of the,
maybe the challenges
you had along the way,
and just, basically,
how you resolved those
and things you'd like to share.
Tyler, you wanna start us off?
- [Barhydt] Sure, yeah.
One of our big ones was really,
because of that fragmentation I mentioned,
we had a lot of those lost toys.
15, that's nothing.
And we had a ton of
stuff in the environment
that we just didn't know either,
what it was, what was on it,
it had been there for a long time.
It was, you know,
one person using an
application, et cetera.
And so, really, kind of,
understanding that the ecosystem,
whether you have a good CMDB or not,
or you just, you need something to come in
and help with discovery.
It was, we were able to
identify a ton of prior retains
and we, I mean, we ran into
the same VMware cost thing.
So we reduced from about
05,000 cores down to 22
in about nine months just through
those efforts of, kind of,
re-pushing and really driving
from an IT perspective
into the application
owners in the business
and calling out like, okay,
do you really need it?
'Cause their first answer was always yes.
And I mean, we identified
and, again, AS400 stuff
that had been out there for a while.
We just kept pushing.
So it was almost like, don't
take retain as the first answer
or don't take their first
answer as the truth.
You've gotta push on it.
Which seems a little
weird sometimes from IT
of where we're pushing the business
on the need of their applications.
- [Blankenstein] Were you
empowered to make those decisions?
- We were, we, you know,
we partnered with them.
Probably shouldn't say it out loud,
sometimes I'm looking for
the illusion of choice,
and some of those conversations,
but little bit of that
leading them to the,
hey, here's where we're headed
and here's what we're gonna do.
- [Blankenstein] But a
common vision is, ultimately,
what you were after.
- [Barhydt] Yes, yeah, yeah.
- [Blankenstein] Angel, you
wanna share a few things?
- Yeah, I think, well, for us,
the main challenge was at
the beginning, time, right?
Because we decided to use EVS,
we came up with the idea of EVS this year.
We planted it this year and
we executed it this year.
So the time was really,
really challenging.
And we needed to talk
with cybersecurity teams,
with architectures team
to see how this will work.
And then contact our partner, DXC,
start looking into the
solution, how we'll work,
how do we connect,
how do we extend this
VLAN and this connectivity
to the EVS environment
and start looking into all these pieces
and then taking the teams together
and see how their applications run,
if they will have some
concerns, if they don't,
if they have the time to test,
because they were, as I mentioned,
they were focusing on other
modernization and other things.
So I think those ones were
one of the biggest challenges.
And then-
- So you had,
you got their buy-in early to do testing,
you didn't have to pull them
off their development projects,
but as you migrated
infrastructure, they had,
you had their buy-in,
I guess, to validate.
- Yeah, they needed to validate
and also the user, right?
And also then go to the business
and then, hey, we are
moving these workloads
that are really, really
big, really important.
They already, all the company
knows how is our strategy
for the main and the critical
applications that we have.
So taking this different
approach was a bit difficult
with them, just for, show them,
hey, we, we will move this workloads
in a different manner that you're used to.
So you need to test and
you need to help us.
And now it's a shorter timeframe.
So that was a challenge as well.
But also we will learn in the way that,
at the beginning, as I
discussed previously here
in our conversations,
EVS was only a transition point.
Well, we were thinking in only
moving our workloads to EVS
to then start moving to another plans,
another modernization plans
that we will discuss later.
But one of the things
that we find out there
is that all these benefits
and all this agility that even EVS gave us
as a transition point,
we started to think,
hey, what happens if we
keep some workloads here,
not all of them, because, of
course, we have other plans.
But those were one of the things
that we started learning there,
and at the end we started
reducing some costs
because we already moved some
of our workloads to the Cloud.
So we have on-prem services
with bigger servers
with a big environment that
we didn't need anymore.
So also when we moved
everything to the EVS,
we reduced some costs.
- What was the learning
curve, if there was one,
for the EVS move?
You had VMware knowledgeable
administrators and staff?
- Yeah, I think the key point here is that
I think the knowledge that
our partner and my team has,
it was like kind of the same.
Of course, we needed to learn a bit,
but as I mentioned, the
challenge was the time.
So they keep up, they start
scaling up this Countdown
or this service with EVS help us a lot
because we have the main person to help us
with this solution and
with this challenges.
So the learning curve
was really, really short.
- Was there any resistance
to just the whole concept
of moving to the Cloud?
I mean, a lot of people
like to run their workloads
in the place that they
built them maybe, you know?
- Well, I mean, at the
beginning, of course,
we have some barriers, some pushback.
But at the end we needed to move them.
- Needed to move.
- So, yeah.
- You had some real deadlines.
You had a bigger objective
to close data centers?
- Correct, correct.
The bigger objective was
close the data center
and not doing a tech refresh.
- Gotcha.
Thank you, that was really helpful.
Molly, oh, oh, I'm not ready to move on.
- So for lessons learned for us, you know,
when we first started,
prior to me coming to
office of the president,
the systemwide office,
they had given AWS to a
lot of people in my group.
They're like, hey, we'll
give you some training.
Here's some access, fly, be free.
You know, just mess around.
I would not suggest that as a strategy.
When I came into the organization,
people were really excited about AWS,
that part was really cool
that people were really
interested in the Cloud.
But what we had is people messing around,
doing things that cost us a lot of money,
doing things that weren't
set up in a secure way,
adding a lot of value.
And so, you know, then I had
to sort of claw it all back.
So that part was not ideal.
We did get interest,
but you can't just have people
throwing an app up into AWS
but keeping the database,
you know, in the data center.
So lots of things like that
where people just didn't know
because they were learning.
What we brought in, I
brought in a Cloud leader
who had a lot of experience doing Cloud
at two different other organizations
who set standards, had governance,
put in the FinOps things,
and we went from $50,000 a
month to $10,000 a month in cost
and, you know, massively
increased security.
But I was very unpopular when
I sort of clawed it all back.
So that was one of my lessons learned is
from the very beginning,
you need to have governance,
you need to have standards, and
you need to have leadership,
not just, you know, our partners,
but you need to have leadership in IT
that knows what we're gonna
do and how we're gonna do it.
Another big lesson learned
for me is our big project
that we were moving
that HR payroll system,
that our very first project
to AWS we had it all planned.
We had a budget and then COVID
hit and our budget got cut.
And, you know, it was
really disappointing.
But, you know, the team, just,
my team didn't wanna
tell the vendor anything.
Like, we don't talk to
the vendor, you know,
they're just gonna sell us stuff.
But treating the vendor
like a business partner
and saying, hey, this
is what happened to us,
we really wanna do this,
but our budget got cut
and we don't see a way to do it.
And just saying like, you know,
this is the reality of the situation.
And then we were able to get
AWS to figure some things out
with some of the programs that they had
that we weren't even aware of.
And that was what enabled
us to move forward.
So whether it's AWS
or any other vendor that you're
going to work with closely,
treating them like a business partner
and just telling them what's
going on, this is our problem.
And maybe they can't help you,
but at least you have trust.
Or maybe they can help you
in ways that you may not have fathomed
because they're going to have access
to these different programs
that you might have.
So I think it's,
that's a big thing is,
when there's problems,
when you think you have to cancel,
when there's problems with leadership,
whatever it is, just, you know, be honest
and be straight up.
I mean, they're already
your business partners.
You may as well let them in on
it to help solve the problem.
- Yeah, can I pile on?
- Yeah, please, yeah.
- Something similar, right?
When starting out,
we had a couple of folks
that were doing FinOps
and they were kind of isolated.
They were in their own
little groups and we,
they were pulled together recently,
I think just ahead of
when I actually got there.
And we had actually
started that discipline
within the organization.
And I wouldn't do this without it, right?
So if there's one thing
you're gonna set up first,
it would be a FinOps.
Get an idea of what's going
on in the environment,
have the ability to find it.
We've identified it a ton,
we've identified a ton
of wasted infra on-prem,
and we identified a ton in our
Cloud environments as well.
But we stay on top of it.
So we get the alert, we've,
they've got partnership
out into the business
and it works really well
when you show 'em the dollars
and you go in and it's
like, hey, what happened?
And it's not a month later,
it's not two months later,
it's a day.
It's within that first week, typically,
that we identify that.
And again, like you mentioned,
take advantage of the programs,
whether it be MAP or other, right?
For the Migration Assistance Program.
Those things work with
and partner with either your partner
and/or AWS to take
advantage of those programs.
- Anything else you wanna add?
- I totally agree on take
advantage of the MAP program,
as well, we used that.
And the FinOps, yeah.
At the beginning we have some questions
on how this different
approach with EVS will work,
but, of course, having
this, all these procedures,
all the team, all the force,
all the knowledge from
AWS to control the budget
to control this FinOps approach.
It's really important for
taking this kind of strategies.
- And it sounds like, I think I heard,
common across all three companies,
getting that centralized buy-in
and sort of a center of
excellence established,
really important setting a precedent
for how this can be successful.
Molly, I remember you saying, you know,
getting focused on a particular
application, you know, it's like-
- Well we had burning platform
after burning platform,
so it was easy.
(panelists laugh)
- That makes it, makes it
easy to pick, I suppose.
Great, well, very interesting.
So let's transition now.
Now that you are all
running workloads in AWS,
I'm curious on your thoughts
about what the future,
what's on your roadmap, you
know, modernization plans
or if you've already modernized what's,
just, what's coming for you?
Angel, why don't we
start with you this time?
- Sure, well, right now
we are around, like,
we will end up 2025, around 25-90%
of our applications on Cloud
with different strategies.
Of course, we need to keep moving ahead
and start maturing our applications,
mainly our tier three and
tier one applications.
So, talking about the
applications that we have in EVS,
we have a couple of options there.
Our tier three and our tier one,
they will go through a refactoring process
or a re-platform process for sure.
But now we are starting
to look into what tier two
and tier three apps need to be modernized,
which one of them will be retired
because maybe some of the features
will go to another application
that we already have been modernized
or which one of them will stay there.
And then, if we are keeping
some of those applications
in EVS is, how do we
improve the reliability?
Or if we have, if we start to,
we need to start thinking
in maybe having another
region from AWS for DRP,
as DRP for our back plan for EVS.
So that's, I think
that's one of the things
that we're looking into,
that our modernizations will keep going.
We have all of our strategies
that will leverage all the modernization
that we already have.
So it's important to keep
moving along the modernization.
- And your teams are continuing
to do modernization
activities, developers.
- They will still continue,
they will still continue
mainly for one of our towers
that they have some
applications left, to 2026.
Our plan is actually to end up
with all our applications
on Cloud for 2026
and decommission all the
three big main data centers
that we have for 2026 as well.
- Great.
Molly, you want to go next?
- Yeah, so we had started this
process, you know, years ago,
and then we really kind of finished up.
So we recently put
everything we had into AWS
and we got done a little bit faster
than we had originally planned
because of the VMware
sort of financial crisis
that was coming our way.
So there are some things
that we can continue to do to modernize
because we wanted to do
things a certain way,
but, because of the VMware thing,
we had to move really, really fast.
So we're going back
and doing some of the
modernization efforts
and some of those things moved over.
The other piece is,
and this is sort of not my usual strategy,
but some of the partners
that we signed up with at the beginning,
we had a partner that took
over our HR and payroll system
because at the time we didn't
have a lot of Cloud people.
We didn't really know what we're doing.
We're like, they're gonna be
better at managing than us.
Over time we've grown,
we've grown to be,
honestly, better at doing it
than they are.
And so, you know, they
make a lot of mistakes,
they charge us a lot of money
and we actually put
together a plan recently
that says we're gonna keep, it's on AWS,
we're gonna keep it on AWS,
but we're gonna take it back.
I don't normally wanna do that.
Usually you get people who are out there
and they really are good at this stuff.
But our HR payroll system,
I'm just gonna say it,
it's a little customized.
It's not cookie cutter, it's not easy.
It's PeopleSoft, its old, you
know what I'm talking about,
Some of you, okay?
And it's very custom.
So this vendor isn't great at doing it,
but we are because we live it.
So we're gonna pull that back in
and we're gonna hire 10 people
to do the, basically do
the care and feeding of it.
But I think our team's
gonna be better at it.
That's what I've found
'cause we've, over time,
we've been able to hire people
that are all Cloud people.
We don't have to be in two worlds.
- Gotcha.
Tyler, why don't you share some things?
- We had a blend of things to do, right,
with the, those kind of
disparate data centers.
So we had some applications
that we were able to, kind of,
modernize as we went.
We had some that made sense
based on data gravity,
like I mentioned before
that ended up in Azure.
But we focused in on that.
We ended up, like I mentioned, doing AVS
and that was just again, to get us out.
- Right.
- Shut down data centers.
We plan on being out of all data centers.
There's one that really doesn't count
that'll be there for longer term,
but somebody else manages it
outside of the company, but-
So we plan on being out late 26,
maybe a little bit into 27,
where we'll be full Cloud
in a hybrid because we do
have some other SaaS stuff
that runs actually out in Oracle.
But from a modernization
perspective, that's our goal now is
as we move those things into AVS,
now we're gonna modernize out of there
and into AWS if, again,
if there's some workload
that makes sense, we can
put it wherever we want.
But the majority of
that's gonna go that way.
We plan on leveraging the migration lab.
So we're in talks with
them right now on finding
and identifying the right workload.
We had stuff-
- That the modernization lab?
- Yes, the AWS modernization lab.
So we're working with them
to identify the right target
for that, to leverage some
of those things that can
kind of use some of the
new tooling, et cetera
to kind of modernize,
give us, upgrade the code,
document stuff that we, you
know, some poor guy that came in
and the developer that is long
gone, so he's a, you know,
he has inherited that environment.
So what do you do to put
some of that stuff in place?
We had issues with HA and DR capability.
So that alone was enhanced
as we migrated our workloads
where it made sense.
So we still have some things that are,
don't have as stringent of SLAs
and things like that around it.
So we've kind of tried to manage that,
but we also have a lot of applications
that are moving to either an off the shelf
or SaaS platform that will
just need to ride out, right?
So we have some to keep the lights on.
So we may choose not to modernize those
and just ride 'em out
and then make sure that we
can decom 'em in the end.
So we've got every flavor of, kind of,
thing going on in the environment
that we have to manage.
- As you have ongoing
education for your teams,
things like the AWS, Well
Architected Framework,
and all that.
- Yeah, we leverage, again,
I don't think I'd said
Skill Builder yet here,
but when we were talking earlier,
I actually referenced
it to my cab ride over.
He was saying he was learning AWS
and so I pushed him towards Skill Builder
as an example of where
to go find, you know,
those types of things
and classes and things that you can take.
So we leveraged that heavily
and we've also blended the teams together.
So we actually, the folks
that were in the on-prem,
obviously they helped
and did a lot of that migration into AVS,
which would be similar
with the EVS solution.
And we were partnering
them up on the migrations
and really trying to cross train
and just get them together as a group
versus this whole,
we're two separate teams
and things like that.
And Skill Builder has been huge
on that upskill of our folks.
- Great, great.
Is that something you make
you of as well, Angel?
- Yeah, and I want to add here that,
not only focusing on EVS,
but all other applications
that we are doing these modernizations,
we are working today with,
our architecture team
is trying to make a framework
about how do we need
to mature every application
that we have to make
to really leverage and
have all the advantages
that the refactor and maturity can give us
to our applications.
So this is something that,
is this how, a work in progress
and it's part of the modernization plan
that we have already.
- Molly, anything to add?
- Yeah, I think that because
we've been doing this
over a long period of time,
you know, as people leave,
we've really been saying, okay,
we're going towards Cloud,
so we're going to hire more Cloud people.
So it's not like we started with a team
of a lot of Cloud experts.
We, you know, had a couple.
But over time, as you know,
you're going there every
time someone leaves,
we bring in somebody who's
really focused on that area.
And we also take advantage a lot
of the training that's offered.
'Cause there are people who are interested
in going that direction and can learn.
But we also, I have a
pretty aging organization.
The average age of,
you guys are gonna be
surprised when you hear this,
but the average age of IT
at my organization is 51.
Because a lot of people,
when they go to the UC,
they go there to retire,
to get a pension, right?
So we have a lot of older folks.
So of those-
- And you have their records still?
- Yeah.
- For 99 years,
- For 99 years.
- 99 years, we gotta keep it.
So because of that, I mean
some of those folks, you know,
they're interested in learning,
but some of 'em are like,
Hey, I'm only gonna,
I'm only gonna be here
for like three more years.
You know, they kind of ride it out.
So we have different people there,
but we've been largely successful
at building that team out.
- Great, great, great.
Any other modernization thoughts
while we're on the topic?
- I mean anything you can do
to go with that automation
first kind of mindset,
kind of get folks out of
even the manual build,
manual builds, right?
- Infrastructure as code.
- Yeah, infrastructure as
code, the Terraform stuff.
The things that we did
to kind of push that a little bit too is,
I think, it's every, every week
when we're on this get together,
I have an employee of mine
that's constantly saying,
hey, just give me more, gimme more, right?
So I'm like, like fill his queue.
Like keep him busy because
there's so many things out there
that we can do from an
automation perspective
that we just weren't taking advantage of.
So I think we're getting into that
and building that out as we go as well.
- And did you leverage any
of the Terraform things?
- Yeah, we, actually, we're
following also strategies
with Amazon Queue, for
example, for our developers.
They are using, they
are using it a bit more.
And the idea here is for
them to be more agile,
to keep modernizing to-
And now the new request from the business
will come out really, really
fast with all this effort
and all this modernization that we have.
- Yeah, and for EVS specifically,
did you script the build
of your environment?
You did, I know you
stretched your networks
and you did migrations.
How did you actually do the migrations?
Did you just, you did live migrations
or you did 'em at night?
- We did it at night actually, yeah.
At the beginning of course it was a lot
of planning before that.
- Yeah.
- But yeah,
of course all of our
migrations were at night.
We need really small timeframes.
One, one hour and a half
because of our operations.
But yeah, we did at night.
- Thinking ahead to maybe
future modernization
of those workloads, things
like AWS transfer for VMware,
that's something that could
potentially play into discovery
of that environment if you,
if you're trade choose.
- Yeah, we're trying to look into a way
to transform, actually.
To start moving those
applications to the Cloud.
- But as you said, they're
fine where they are.
If you-
- You know, I'll just mention something
'cause you said Amazon queue.
We did find something that was
helpful with that recently.
We have, unfortunately,
'cause we are an education organization,
we have some custom stuff.
Okay, we have a lot of custom stuff.
I wish we had zero custom stuff,
but we do, so there's a tool in queue
that allows you to go from
Java 17 to 21 with help
with their, with basically the AI help.
And so we did use, utilize
that for all of our 17
to maybe to 25, 21.
It was actually really helpful.
The team was really suspect of it.
They said, we'll try it
with one and we'll see.
But they were pretty happy with it.
- Wonderful.
- Yeah, I think, with stuff
like that, as it matures
and you can take advantage
of it, I mean we're even,
I mentioned a bunch of
kind of keep the lights on
and these apps that we might write out.
It still may be a value if
it's that one developer,
we don't know that much.
And so we're afraid to touch it
or we're afraid to patch it
that we may still go ahead
and throw it at these tools
just to see what we get.
So it's like getting people to change
that mindset a little bit
of like, why not, right?
Let's go ahead and throw this at it,
see what it produces.
And if it's easier to understand
and maintain, even though
we're just gonna, kind of,
ride it out for the next
year and a half or two,
it still makes sense to run
through those types of tools.
- Yeah.
Any other thoughts on modernization?
All right, well if you,
thank you very much.
That was a great, great discussion.
I think it was really
beneficial for everybody.
If you are interested in
learning how you can get started,
we recommend these basic steps.
First, assess your VMware estate.
We think the best way to
do this is with an OLA,
an Optimization and Licensing Assessment.
Customers tell us this is
extremely valuable to them,
even before they implement
the recommendations
of the assessment.
A lot of the information
provided is beneficial
and can actually save you money.
Second is leverage the
AWS partner network.
We have over 460 migration
competency partners
who can help you with your migration.
So don't hesitate to work with them.
As you've seen several
of our customers here
have done that with various partners.
Next, decide on your
approach and strategy.
I mean, do you wanna start
with a single application?
Maybe help improve performance
or increase resiliency?
Or perhaps you're facing
a hardware refresh
or a data center lease expiration
and you've got a compelling event,
you've got to make a decision
and move the whole thing
and plan a full data center migration.
But once you've decided on your approach,
we can help you with
training, support, services,
purpose-built technologies.
We've got ISV tools that can
help with migration services
and also the incentive programs,
MAP, as was mentioned several times.
We have these services,
we really wanna help you.
So please partner with
your AWS account team.
If you have a technical account manager,
if you have an account SA,
don't hesitate to ask them
what they can, you know,
bring to the table for you
in terms of funding or like I said,
third party tools, et cetera.
Excuse me.
I also wanna leave you with these QR codes
for a few resources that
you can leverage this week,
including the AWS for
VMware, re:Invent the guide.
This will help you quickly locate
interesting VMware sessions
at the conference this week.
We've got a nice blog post together
with all of those put together.
Next, there's a link on getting started
with a migration assessment.
This will help you reduce costs
and build your business case.
And then finally, a link to
the AWS for VMware website
where you can keep up
with our latest offerings
and announcements.
And then this eye chart here, sorry,
please feel free to take
a photograph of this,
but this is a slide
showcasing all the additional
AWS for VMware sessions
happening this week at re:Invent.
A couple to call out, there's
an AWS Transform Workshop
Tuesday at 12:30 PM,
as well as two AWS
transform breakout sessions
on Wednesday morning.
And there's a number of chalk talks,
including an Amazon EVS Deep
Dive Wednesday afternoon,
as well as an EVS deep
dive into networking
and storage architecture on Thursday.
Also, please stop by our migration
and modernization neighborhood
in the AWS Village
for demonstrations and
Q&A with our experts.
And again, thank you all for your time.
Please give special
thanks to our panelists.
Thank you for being
here, really insightful.
Appreciate you all making
the effort to be here.
And please remember to
complete the session survey
in the mobile application
for this session.
It is MAM203, MAM203.
Thank you again for your time.